when you studied a little bit about
harry potter i
felt something else come into me
and magic is deception magic is
all lies and was labeled by many as the
father of satanism
he was the founder of the church of
satan or even a person who goes and
asks someone to do magic for them
this takes you out of islam he is
considered as the most notorious satanic
magician of the 20th century
have you ever accompanied one of these
rockies have you ever witnessed
something do you have any uh
i've been involved here you have can you
share with us
can you share with us a jin story got my
soul i sold my soul for you
now figure that out and i think he got
possessed but they found out in the end
he got possessed by
or black magic is based on the worship
of satan and neglecting the worship of
god
what do you say for our agnostic atheist
friends when they hear this they say oh
that's the reason i don't follow any
religion but at the same time you know
these are the people who are really the
most into aliens and ufos and stuff like
that
magically written i made it to bargain
the chief commander
on this earth and this earth and then in
the world we can't it's so great to be
on the dean's show
this is the dean show welcome back to
the show and i have this week's special
guest
sheikh abdul rahim green how are you
sheik
alhamdulillah very well eddie how are
you doing man i'm good alhamdulillah how
are things
on your part of the world over there um
you know summer's coming uh the sun's
out
um it's nice bro you know life is
looking up we hope the lockdown's gonna
end
so uh you know inshallah you know
we see you here and there getting out
you know uh enjoying the nice ambiance
there you got the mountains uh doing
some hiking
drinking some coffee well right now i'm
at some mountain biking trails with my
boys and usually i get a signal here
but i was at the top of the hill and
like there was no signal so i just
nipped in the car and drove down a
little bit and now i've got signals so
uh yeah it's it's all good now
alhamdulillah i was my plan was to um
you know sit in the car and do the show
and the boys just sort of mess around
but uh
yeah one of them is going to go off now
so now we've heard you connect make the
connection between
where you got harry potter magic and
agile
and many many don't know you spent some
time
studying studying studying this topic
what was the goal of that
i did i still have the book it's called
the magical arts i still have that book
somewhere in my library
um and um and a few other books i had so
basically like a lot of people who are
on spiritual journeys
they go through the whole of the new age
spirituality thing right so yoga
psychosomatic yoga chakras psychic
energy
um you know all of that type of stuff
and you know that
eventually that's it's going to lead you
looking into magic
now it's it's sort of ironic that in
fact it actually
gave me the first sort of glimpses of
tohid
now that may sound weird however if you
understand that
a very important part of western
you know of western magic is the
kabbalah
right so the jewish this is actually a
jewish book of magic
but it has influenced western magical
law quite strongly the kabbalah and
and the kabbalah actually has some you
know some clear things about tawheed in
it
right because obviously it's rooted
uh some of it in the torah of course we
believe there's a lot of corruption
there and a lot of deviation and a lot
of misguidance right
but some of the things it was saying it
was like okay that sounds more like the
sort of god that i believe in because i
i was really struggling with this
christian notion of god
um sitting on a cloud you know reaching
out his finger and touching adam you
know like michelangelo
uh style uh you know um system chapel in
the vatican you know that famous picture
so-called of god with a gray beard
sitting there start naked
and adam you know reaching out with his
finger um i really struggle with that i
i just couldn't understand you know this
surely wasn't god
right it's not the god i believed in i
just couldn't believe that the creator
of the whole universe
was some old man sitting on a cloud um
so
i i guess that's part of the reason as
well why i started just looking through
all sorts of things
you know another thing that impacted me
funnily enough was star wars
right because star wars talked about the
force
you know may the force be with you and
again the idea that there was this force
that there was some force in the
universe
you know it made more sense to me than
the you know the this christian
anthropomorphic idea of god um
so i i don't know all of these things
were sort of i guess in a way
some of them were appealing to my fitra
you know my natural
this because we believe eddie as you
know that every human being
is created with a natural inclination
or a natural disposition to worship god
alone
and it's only their environment that
takes them away from that
basic fundamental nature um
and but you know this this nature
surfaces
every now and then right so you know for
example
you know when you are like you know like
the quran
gives an example of a man in a boat and
there's a storm in the sea
and you know the people think they're
gonna drown and then they call upon god
and
all the things that they used to worship
and they used to put their trust in
their money and their trade and their
idols and
they forget it all and it's like god
save me god help me so this tohi
this this natural belief in the oneness
of god
emerges at those times what do you think
about
when you studied a little bit about
harry potter and it's
in it and it's innocent enough people
think that you actually find it in some
islamic school libraries have you heard
of that yeah
yeah yeah i mean i didn't know that but
to be honest
um what her name rowling
i can't remember her name um ak
rowling right i've heard some interviews
with her
like first of all when i started read i
only read the first two books i read the
first two books of harry potter
myself right and i just found it like to
be honest by
you know i was really bored yeah however
what yeah i found it really boring right
uh and a bit repetitive but
you know people told me all the the
books got better um
further on but you know i just gave up
and i to be honest i don't have time for
it right
um but you know my you know my i know my
son
one of my sons really liked it he read
it all um i remember
i think i got him the the the last book
i got in one of the first copies that
came out
you know on day one or something so um
but uh but you see the thing is bro i
don't like
generally with my kids i don't uh
keep them away from stuff like that but
i use it as a platform to explain things
to them
so i you know so because i understand
like
there is no doubt that jk rowling had
had studied
magic thoroughly the stuff in there
is like if you know magic you know that
a lot of the things
are either directly taken from
actual magic law or they
are you know like a little bit borrowed
and she mixes up a bit of this and a bit
of that and changes the name here
but it's not just magic as well the
whole i mean which is i'm
i'm i'm still fascinated by it the whole
mythology of ancient britain
right and not just ancient britain but
mostly like ancient europe it has all
these legends and these mythologies
and you know tales of these like
spirits and ghosts and you know gods and
creatures
and stuff so there's a lot of that mixed
in it
as well there's also stuff taken from
you know stuff that's probably actually
genuine so like herbology
for example the whole study of herbs
like before there was west you know
before there was the allopathic medicine
everything was herbs right so this whole
thing of
herbs like medicine and magic were
actually
quite mixed up right so not
everything from it was actually
necessarily bad
some of it was like pro you know was
actually good stuff right
um which makes it even more confusing
right
so yeah having studied magic having
looked into it and then having read
harry potter
no doubt at all that and she's admitted
it right she's
talks about the books she's read and
they are
you know books of magical law you know
laura is in l.o.r.e not laura's in you
know
the law of the land type law yeah law
means sort of
like legends and um it's not just
legends right
i suppose it's equivalent of a type of
magical
sharia i suppose yeah
but yeah and a lot of this eddie is
based on like you look if you read harry
potter
um even in harry potter although like
she will paint you know
harry potter and jemimy or whatever i
can't remember their names right
um as like sort of good guys against the
evil voldemort he whose name shall not
be mentioned
right um like but in reality they're all
part of the same spectrum because even
when harry and hermione are doing spells
those spells and the potions they make
are full of filth they are full of
natchez
they contain every single like um
filthy thing right so you know blood
and frogs and you know things that are
haram that are forbidden
um you know various plants that are
basically poisonous
right and these incantations many of
them
obviously contain words of disbelief
uh and all of so that from that
perspective right this is when the
shayateen when the devils
right will cooperate with you they will
cooperate with you
and they will help you do evil things
but you first have to like sell your
soul to the devil
and you do that by saying things of
disbelief
even sacrificing children uh this is not
just fantasy
right this is real stuff when you hear
about kids being kidnapped
when you hear in nigeria and places in
africa and it's not just in africa it's
right here in uk and it's not like don't
think it's just
you know restricted to you know black
people and voodoo no
this stuff takes place right um
and you know they will sacrifice
children they will desecrate the bible
obviously in islamic countries they will
desecrate the quran
right and this is what they do in order
to get the shayateen
and the jinn to work with them and
cooperate with them one more question on
the harry potter before i go to the next
do you think this can be some is this
sometimes a deliberate attempt can we
take it
is that or is it a far stretch that uh
these shows like harry potter books like
harry potter is like a g
rated version or a stepping stone for
people now to get into
possibly even a higher level you know on
the topic of magic
possibly yeah i think it's all i to be
honest
um eddie this is a very i there's some
research
more research i have to do on this
but i think that when you when you link
this to the whole
issue of this movement of the illuminati
now
you know there is some evidence that
some guys
started this conspiracy theory about the
illuminati
ruling the world as a type of joke as a
type of you know
they literally chose it there was this
bavarian
group called the illuminati that
actually existed
right and they started publishing stuff
you know the illuminati and they did
this just to show how conspiracy
theories were so
stupid and just to prove that it's just
a lot of nonsense
and it was almost like sarcasm right um
and that because these guys believed i
don't remember their names i was
watching a documentary about it
and these guys basically believed that
conspiracy theories were a means of
control that the elite
used right in order to control people
right and only really stupid people
would believe this stuff
because when you believe in conspiracy
theories you're disempowered right you
think oh the whole world is controlled
by this cabal
right we'll never be able to overcome
them they control every aspect of your
life and you become hopeless
right obviously unless you have rooting
in tawheed you're never hopeless and you
know but
above every power is the power of allah
but it could quite be it could quite
it's i think
the thing is the funny thing is that
people began to take it seriously and
not only did they take it seriously
it is quite possible that some people
actually then
started reviving it and because they
dabble in magic
and witchcraft and all of these things
and because
i mean the illuminati were originally a
rationalist
movement they were nothing to do with
the occult at all
right the illuminati originally were all
to do with enlightenment and the use of
reason
uh and a rationalist movement that's
what they were all about
right but i it could be well that these
guys have actually
sort of taken it and now adopted it to
this whole magical thing so
i definitely think there's some stuff
going on right there is no
doubt and a lot of this new age stuff a
lot of this stuff where these people
are and this is like some of their
people amongst the elite believe this
that literally
they they have this idea that you are
god everyone is god you can become god
you can become a deity you can
like this is the you have to understand
the
underlying philosophy of most magic and
this is hinduism as well and hinduism
is full of magic right it's widely
practiced
so this is the belief that the universe
is god
and god is the universe so this is the
opposite of tawheed tohi teaches
that the creator is distinct from the
universe
he is not part of it he is not contained
within it
he is the creator of it and the creator
and the creation
are two different things but this whole
hindu-based magic based philosophy
has the opposite idea it says the
universe is god
right and therefore you are part of god
everything is part of god and they
believe that
if you develop enough spiritual powers
and you
learn how to channel all of these
energies
you can control the universe in other
words you can control god
right and you can bring enough power
within yourself to become a sort of
divine being and i'm sure you can see
eddie how that leads to the dajjal
right because the dajjal is going to
claim some sort of divinity for himself
and he is
going to have these sort of supernatural
powers to do incredible things
right but this only happens through
kuffar so one of the things that the
you know the job will do is he will go
to a man
he will say to him believe in me the man
will say no i won't believe in you
he said what if i bring your brother and
your father back to life
and if what if i bring your camels back
to life because he's a bedouin he says
if you do that i'll believe in you i
believe you're the rabb so what he will
do is get two
gin to shayateen to or three share team
to take before some devils
to take the form of his brother and to
take the form
of his uh father and to take the form of
his camels and this is how the man will
be
deceived right so it is clear that a
dajjal
is using magic and the jinn
and these type of things to deceive
people and that's the thing about magic
eddie
magic is deception magic is all lies
that's the whole basis of it whether
it's actually
trick magic tricks the whole point is
deception right
but even black magic is deception
because in black magic what you're doing
is you're using the shayateen and the
jinn in order to make people think that
you have divine powers
right that's the thing so you you don't
tell people
hey guys i'm working with shaitan over
here and this gin over here he's giving
me all of this information right and
he's doing all of these things no
the whole point is to make people think
that you have the power
right and that you are some sort of
divine
powerful being right and this is all to
fool people
into this idea that divinity is within
you
and you know somehow the universe is the
divine and by channeling these energies
and it's all
just a big deception yeah of shaytan
in your studies of some of these books
on magic
did you ever come across uh the founder
of the church of satan's uh
materials um anton levay
anton levay was an american occultist
and was labeled by many as the father of
satanism
he was the founder of the church of
satan and the religion of levi and
satanism
he authored several books including the
satanic bible
the satanic rituals and the satanic
witch
here you can see him do a satanic hand
sign
does it look familiar to you this hand
sign is very prevalent in the music
industry
this is not just a mere coincidence the
devil is hiding in plain sight
who wrote the satanic bible and they
in there he's he he he uh uses many of
these uh
symbolic uh satanic symbolism
that people connect and they see a lot
of these uh rap artists and many of
these musicians
using these things from people like his
books and you know the pentagram
have you come across any of these things
and what's your thoughts on that um
no uh to be honest uh eddie i haven't i
don't know that guy particularly
but i'm familiar with you know the
writings and the teachings of aleister
cowley
right this is a lester crowley dressed
as an egyptian pharaoh
he is considered as the most notorious
satanic magician
of the 20th century he identifies
himself as the prophet entrusted with
guiding humanity into the age of horus
in the early 20th century
horus is yet again an egyptian god
here you see rap artist jay-z wearing a
quote
to what thou wilt which comes from the
philosophy of dilemma
which was developed by a lester crowley
he was
right um i think he lived you know maybe
like 100
120 years ago or something i'm not
really sure right
um but you know he claimed actually to
be the antichrist
right at one time right he actually
claimed it right
and you know he was you know really
responsible for reviving
uh in the uk especially that's where he
was based
you know the whole issue of the occult
uh
and you know that type of stuff so he
was really into this and he was really
trying to revive it
and you'd be very very surprised bro how
influential some of these
uh groups are right um you have another
group called the rosic
rose crush rosa christians like i i met
some guy and had conversations with him
they're slightly different they're more
like so these guys
again it's very interesting there's all
these different types of groups
right so some believe that there is a
primal
religion and in fact in some ways uh you
know some of their belief systems are
actually
quite close to islamic belief systems
right
but they sort of believe in a sort of
hidden religion and hidden messages and
a sort of elite
right like this has even happened within
islam
under some extreme type of sufi sex for
example the bartonia
in islamic history the bartonier means
like barton means
hidden right so again these guys that
believe that there was some sort of
deep spiritual knowledge that the
prophet muhammed
taught to only certain people right and
these certain people are privy to this
deep spiritual knowledge that the masses
do not know
right i think this is more like some
type of superiority complex
right and they will use uh basic
ideas that exist within religions right
and they will just use them
right in order to promote their ideas
right so but you know you find a lot of
these people eddie right
actually some of them are really
genuinely you know
spiritual people right in the sense that
i believe some of them are really
looking for god
right they actually are and i'm just
saying that from my own experience right
i didn't go into this stuff because i
you know had some like
you know desire to control people and
you know what it wasn't
i was looking through this stuff because
i knew there was more to reality
than what i was just being told that
we're just here to eat and drink and you
know consume and whatever
so in my search i went through all of
these things
right and you know some of them have
some sort of basis
but unfortunately what i think is the
reality of it has been twisted
and turned and you know manipulated in a
wrong way
you know how do you explain when you see
people like you know you link aleister
crowsley
and then he has his book which people
like eminem and
others you know they go and do some of
the things that are in
his book that that connection to the
unseen world of the jinn and then
famous people like bob dylan have you
heard of him he's a famous musician
of course i didn't know he was into that
stuff yeah there's a quote of him on a
60-minute interview he talks about
how i i he talks about the magic and
it's a different kind of magic that
he was involved in and how the bargain
that he made with the chief commander
and then when he was asked which chief
commander he said of this world and the
next he's talking about like
it's almost like he's talking about
iblees you know you ever look at music
that you've written and look back at it
and say whoa
that surprised me i don't know how
i got to write those songs well those
early songs were like almost magically
written
um that there's a magic to that
and it's not uh siegfried and roy kind
of magic you know it's a
it's a different kind of a penetrating
magic why do you still do it why are you
still out here
well it goes back to the destiny thing
and i made a
bargain with it you know long time ago
and
i'm holding up my hand what was your
bargain
to get where uh i am now
should i ask who you made the bargain
with with
with you know with the chief uh chief
commander
on this earth and this earth
and then in the world we can't see where
are we they talk about
the the things like beyonce for instance
like uh
there's another uh name sasha that when
she's on stage she's overtaken
by these forces and they take over her i
cannot do when i'm
in rehearsal i mean i can try but then
it just doesn't happen
i can sing notes and sing strong and
do all these things that when i'm just
by myself
i can't do and i remember right before i
performed
i raised my hands up and it was kind of
the first time
i felt something else
come into me and i knew
that was going to be my coming out night
for the bt award
you know the word genius right
you know the word genius you know what
it comes from from
jin from jin wow genie
in greek it's actually an ancient greek
as well right
and so it's because this is what people
used to think
right people used to believe that people
who were geniuses
right were like in
like possessed or they had some not
possessed exactly right
but they were in cahoots with spirits
and these spirits were able to impart
them with certain types of knowledge so
what we find
is in the quran allah talks about this
in the quran
that they you know that the you see the
the peop the
the jewish people who practice magic
obviously not all the jewish people but
some of them who practice magic and then
wrote the kabbalah right and you know
practice this type of stuff
they claim that their knowledge right
claim came from the angels you know came
from
suleiman right they that's what they
claimed
because obviously as we know that allah
actually
did give suleiman command over the jinn
right so this is their what they use as
a justification for it
so they claim that this knowledge of how
to control the jinn and the spirits
was something that had come from solomon
from suleiman
right but as we know from our position
no
that's not what the quran says that's
not what god tells us
god says that this was unique to
sulaiman
it wasn't something that was given to
anyone else in fact what they practiced
was
magic which they learned from haroot and
maroot now
were actually two angels and they came
down to
the people in the time of the babylonian
times but they would
and they would teach people who asked
and wanted it
the understanding of magic now why allah
knows best
maybe the reason why because you know if
you know the details of something you
know how to protect yourself from it but
like everything eddie
right it's a fitnah right it's a test
if you have that knowledge like if i if
i study the knowledge of for example as
people do today
neuro-linguistic programming right
neuro-linguistic programming is actually
a system of manipulating people's minds
right and it's a way of manipulating
their thoughts now
you could use that in a very positive
way you could use that for healing you
could use that for benefiting people
but you could also use that to control
people for nefarious purposes
right the same thing with magic right
you can use that knowledge of magic to
protect people from it
right or unfortunately you could take
that
and use that but haruta maru will warn
everyone if you use this magic
that's it you're finished you're going
to hell forever right
um because there is you know the
magicians will never be successful
unless they repent like the magicians
from the time of far on
right and you can see magic is real and
magic is powerful bro we should not
doubt the power and the reality of magic
you just need to see the story of
pharaoh
that the magicians in the time of egypt
right
um that even they were tamusa
they made their starves appear as if
they were snakes and even it made
musa nervous right even musso when he
saw it
he got nervous so this they you know
they have real abilities
to deceive people and trick people we
shouldn't underestimate
you know uh how powerful it is but you
know obviously
above all of that is the power of allah
and of the creator of of god and you
know if we follow god's way
and we follow his commands and you know
we recite
certain verses of the quran then you
know
these are an amazing protection against
all types of
magic and trickery like that that's what
i was going to get into uh
next after a couple more questions of
how could we be protected you know to
take this really serious uh
you have some people who are have
ambivalent feelings towards this some
just rebuff it off the bat
but how much do you think because you've
studied psychology also
intensely you along with reading the
books of magic and now
this a lot of it before islam and even
in islam now you're you know just always
broadening your horizons studying
learning
how much do you think is there a
connection with a lot of times many of
the mental health issues and other
you know psychological issues that
people are having and they kind of don't
go down this road or some even
you know in every situation people go to
extremes and they just say okay this is
what it is
you know they don't take you know the
other means medical means that we have
but
how much do you think can we can in your
experience can there be a link
between what we're talking about you
know the sir
the evil eye the these things and not
just keep having a balance between it
i think that you know i you know eddie i
haven't really
you know i need to spend a lot more time
thinking about this
yeah un-package it right
um there are things that i thought about
but you know i
haven't put the time and the energy and
the research into it but
you know my initial sort of thoughts
about it seem to indicate to me that
from what we know of the jinn and the
shayateen
and you know because basically they
don't have any control over
us except what we give to them this is
very important
right so like even this issue of jinn
possession
right do i believe that jin can possess
you i do believe they can possess you
however right that it just can't happen
just like that
right the jinn can only possess you
if you create the circumstances
in your life that makes that possible
right it's not i don't believe it's easy
for jinn to possess you
it's only easy when you adopt a
particular lifestyle
that makes it easy so i would compare it
to for example
everyone is a castle you're like it's
imagine like you have a castle
right okay if you maintain the walls and
keep the walls
strong right and keep the gate strong
and you man those walls
right with the right troops yeah and you
have the right stuff ready
to repel the attackers like almost no
one is going to be able to
get into that castle right but if you
leave the gate wide open
and you don't repair the walls right and
you leave
you know the whole thing is in a state
of disrepair it's going to be very easy
for someone to take your castle
and it's the same thing with the
shayateen and the gin
right so it's still it's like but it's
down to you that's your fault that's
your responsibility you've been given
all the tools to protect yourself but
you didn't
you didn't do that right right in fact
you undermined your own castle right
you know you took your soldiers off the
wall and what did you do you had a disco
with them
right and got drunk and took drugs you
know like
so all of those things you dropped it so
yeah then you are going to be opened
the other thing is the way the shayateen
attack us is through suggestion
right so it seems to me that it is
psychology that's what is going on
right and this is what shaitaan when
shaytan saw
adam right and although this is not in
the quran
and i don't i'm not sure it's a hadith
either but you will find it in some
books of tafsir
that you know shaitaan was walking
around adam
and he saw that adam was hollow right
because allah had made him out of clay
and you know allah was leaving adam to
dry and he saw that he was hollow
so he knew that the nature of adam was
that he was going to be
you know he was going to be easy to
influence his desires
because of that hollowness that
emptiness right
okay so this is why they say about the
heart the heart is a vessel that has to
be filled
right if we don't fill that heart with
the remembrance of allah
we will try to fill it with something
else something else that we think is
going to give us
that peace and happiness that we're
looking for right so this is where
shaitaan comes in shaytan is going to
try
and get us to fill our hearts with
anything
except the remembrance of allah right
and so i think that's what it is i
suspect that shaitaan is
a bit of a master psychologist and you
look at the way that he
tricked adam and hawa right he used
psychology
he he he understood their nature
and he manipulated he didn't force them
to do anything what did he do bro he
just whispered
he just whispered to them right but if
you look at his
what he said he was playing
you know he was very clever right people
don't even understand that
shaytan was actually appealing to adam's
religious nature
think about it right because he said
that allah wants you to stop
allah wants to stop you being like
angels
so what what is that about like why
would shaitaan
make that an issue why would shaytan use
that to tempt
adam right so as some scholars pointed
out they said
it's because adam looked at the angels
of something amazing they
are always remembering god they're
always making vikar
they're always praising god remembering
god whereas adam what's adam doing
adam's in the garden eating drinking
enjoying himself right just chilling
right you understand so when shaytan is
saying oh
god wants you to stop you being like
angels he was
using adam's desire to get close to god
to take him away from god he was
using the desire of adam to get close to
god
to take him away from god and this is
very very deep
eddie right it's very deep and very
important even for muslims
we have to be so careful do you have
experience at all or have you seen cases
and how would you compare the two where
you have
obviously one aspect of black magic and
the gin possession you cover
what about sid where you have some
unexplainable things between husband and
wife where all of a sudden you know
their relationship went from good to
just explosive
and nothing's working marriage
counseling all that stuff or brother and
brother
sister and sister you know how does the
aspect of sir you know play and do you
have any experience with this
i i don't deal with it bro on purpose
right
um i'm sure it's real i'm sure it exists
but like i said sir only really comes
to into play when there are already
underlying
you know issues right so
the the the is only going to be taking
hold
when you've already weakened the
fortress examples
no muslim should go without mourning
epcot you know in the night of call
let's talk about
how do you strengthen your fortress
the the basic thing is constant thicker
constantly
like yeah the more you yeah if you if
you are literally
making vicar constantly it is like you
have built the fortress right you
are in an almost you could say
impregnable fortress
right so that could be obviously of car
making dua
reading quran making sure you are in a
state
of wardu constantly saying your prayers
the reason why i don't deal with
anything to do with there's two reasons
yeah
number one the moment you step into that
field and by the way
like it is the i think ibn tamiya won a
great scholar
he said is the greatest jihad is the
jihad against shaitaan
right like so when you actually get into
this
arena of combating shaitaan right it is
just like this
it is the greatest struggle that you can
have right in terms of like how noble it
is how great it
is because he's the biggest tyrant right
you know
um and um but however it comes at a it
can come at a very high cost to you and
your family
right so when you go down that path of
making rookia
and dealing with these issues then
that's it shaitaan is sending his
soldiers to attack you and your family
right so your home like literally which
is not a bad thing right but your home
you have to be reading quran all the
time
everyone has to be praying five times a
day you can't have
anything your food has to be halal your
income has to be
halal right
god your family and yourself constantly
like you said
duas in the morning and the evening you
can't slip up because the moment you
slip up that's that's a way
right so it's literally like the moment
you do that
it's like shaytan is going to be laying
siege to you and your family
right and that is a hard path to follow
right
um but do you see that also in your life
in other duet life do you see that
because now you you
shaytaan lead laying siege to someone
doing rookie what about
others who are calling to the way of
allah you know and getting in the way of
shaytan
well i think obviously bro i think
there's sort of general and specific
yeah right because when you're dealing
with the rookia you're
it's almost like that's the front line
of the battle
right in the sense that you're i guess
you're like fighting it's
more like hand-to-hand combat whereas
yeah like it's like you you're grappling
there bro it's like the hand-to-hand
combat
that's the difference between me saying
to people right like i say
hey guys you know you should study jiu
jitsu you know it's really good it'll
help you
you know do you understand and then
there's you actually teaching people
right how to do it right so which one is
which one is the real more of a real
actual present
and immediate threat right like i can
i can say whatever i like right i
understand who's
yeah you get it bro yeah so but the
thing you hear is bro
is that listen right the reason the
other reason i don't deal with it
directly is a bit like this
right you may also and i'll give give
you an example of jiu jitsu right
in order to practice martial arts right
and especially jiu jitsu for example
i've never practiced it myself but i
have a bit of an idea right
you know you need to maintain a certain
level of fitness
yeah okay you don't need to be the super
fitness guy but look if someone is just
like eating 20 burgers a day
and stuffing his face with cakes and
chocolate you can teach him every move
you like
right but it's he's going to be out of
breath when he lifts one leg
right do you get what i'm saying right
there's just no point
in fact you if you teach him you may
actually cause the guy more
harm right then you do good
so you know you say listen dude you know
lose a better weight shape up a bit
you know whatever or at least you know
you you're gonna come regularly
right and dedicate yourself to that and
show that you know you're gonna make
some changes then i can teach you
it's the same thing here right i will
not help people who don't help
themselves
if someone comes to me and says oh i've
got gin i say do you pray five times a
day
no i said i can't help you i cannot help
you
there's nothing i can do for you because
even if i get all those jin and the
shayateen out
he's gonna bring back 20 30 more if
you're not praying five times a day
right is your money halal or is it all
from ribba and haram and alcohol
well if it's from haram things it
doesn't matter what i do
yeah i can get rid of those shayateen
they're just going to come back more of
them next time
yeah so this is the thing like most
people who have these problems bro
are people they don't pray five times a
day they don't do that
they're involved in haram their food is
haram the drink is haram
their money is haram their life is haram
well of course they're going to be open
to being attacked by shaytan
i had uh sorry i'm laying the smackdown
on everyone bro
it's not that i don't care i do care but
why i'm not going to waste my time you
know what i mean bro
yeah do you think that every community
should have
a trustworthy and experienced rocky
someone in their community
definitely and there's you know like the
few rockies that i know bro
they're saying it's like
bro it's like it's a bit like the
mongols i think you know like when the
people attacked the muslim world like no
one could stop them they were just
everywhere like you know it's like that
with their shia teen like so many people
are suffering so many people
being attacked like there is so much
going on and it's like the crazy thing
is bro
like you know things like harry potter
are normalizing it right they're just
like ordinary people
start to think that magic is cool magic
is fun it's not fun and cool it's flip
it's so dangerous yeah it is so
dangerous it will mess you up
psychologically it will do so much
damage
it's just it's it's really madness right
um you have some muslims actually who
indulge sometimes in this magic
you know if they want to get someone to
love someone or to marry someone
what do you say about that well you know
it's you know it is disbelief a person
who practices it or even a person who
goes
and asks someone to do magic for them
this takes you out of islam you know
it's what they call
koffa kothra means disbelief yeah it is
an
action of disbelief
it is an action of disbelief right and
if you die
not repenting from that you will go to
heaven hell forever and you will never
come out
you mentioned like uh in speaking to
some of these rockies i spoke to one
also
you know people who you would consider
trustworthy who do this for
pretty much you know uh they helped a
lot of people
one of them when i asked how many or he
actually told me he said i
he believes that 80 percent of people
are afflicted by a lot of this stuff you
know what i mean and he mentioned that
every community should have
so and you're you mentioned you similar
that it's kind of like the mongols
so it's it just should it's it should
it should motivate us more to do what
you're saying to
to be more in the dean to be to never
leave
never leave your house you know without
the dua the car
you know even in the morning i mean you
to take this more serious
absolutely bro absolutely i mean look
for for someone who's a rocky
it's a it's a little bit like you know
when
it's your profession you see it a lot
yeah yeah yeah like you know when you
buy a new car and you drive that car
right then suddenly you start seeing
that car everywhere as before you didn't
even notice it
yeah it's a little bit like that you
know when you're doing when it's your
job to do
roku you think the whole world is
possessed right because that's all you
see
day in day out right so i suspect it's
not as bad
as maybe what he said but it is really
bad
right i i won't deny that it is really
like um it's the problem is so big that
we don't have enough
people who are really well trained to
deal with it and it by the way it takes
training and these days i think
to be honest like in order to be a rocky
i do think that
you should have qualifications in
psychology and mental health as well
right because the people i know who are
very le you know i would say reasonably
learned maybe not scholars but good
students of knowledge right
who have also uh studied in depth
psychology
they will say that in their opinion
probably like
90 percent of the things that people
think
are gin possession are not they're
actually just
psychological problems however like i
said i
think the jinn use psychology that's
their method of manipulation so
there may be you know a connection
between the two but like this brother
you know one of the brothers i who you
know and there's a few of them they say
that look
most of these issues are mental health
issues but because the muslim community
are very ignorant about mental health
issues
right uh you know and they just like to
say any problem that someone has you
know even if
like uh their daughter doesn't want to
get married to their cousin back from
back home
right oh she's possessed by a gin that's
how crazy it is
you understand like there's not even
mental health issues right
she's probably quite sensible but you
know
this is it's just ridiculous like you
know
yeah have you ever accompanied one of
these rockies have you ever witnessed
something do you have any uh
i've been involved in you have can you
share with us
can you share with us a jin story or
something people love these
um yeah i mean i you know i i
i did rook here with a lot of other
people
like there was a big group of us and
this is soon after i'd become muslim
on a brother who basically unfortunately
we found out that he had gone into a pub
to go to the toilet right he or he was
muslim right and he wasn't drinking or
anything
he'd just gone into the pub but because
he hadn't he had make the duas and so on
and so forth
he went into the pub he urinated against
the urinal
and i think he got possessed but they
found out in the end he got possessed by
20 female prostitute gin
right and this guy um
they were driving down the motorway like
at 70 miles an hour
right they play started playing quran in
the car
the guy opened the door without even
whatever and literally just jumped out i
mean he didn't they grabbed him
right but he had opened the door and he
was literally on his way to jump out
right fortunately they grabbed him so
um yeah we were pinning this guy down
everyone was reciting the quran
right and but the guy was saying it's me
you know
like he was just like fighting and
fighting and making these
horrific noises yeah it was
you know i won't say i'm not i'm not
honestly i'm not
i really am not scared of the gin at all
it doesn't frighten me it doesn't really
scare me that much i always tell people
they're more scared of you than you are
of them right
i mean it's one of those things when
you're scared of them that's when that's
one of the ways you hand over some sort
of control to them right
so i don't like in a way we shouldn't
like telling jin stories to get people
frightened is just helping shaitaan
right it's actually helping them so
there's
all these horror stories and this type
of stuff that creep you out this is all
part of his plan
right he wants you he wants people to be
afraid of him and his followers but in
reality they have no power
like i said unless you give them the
power they don't have it
right so we don't want to really create
sort of fear
and sort of you know that type of thing
no one should really be afraid of jinn
like you have to realize the real the
gin fled
to the remote places right because
they're afraid of human beings
right originally this is what happened
the jinn would
inhabit the desert regions the deserted
buildings
because they run away from people but
then what would happen
is that you know the arabs when they're
traveling through the desert regions
they would call out oh chief now because
it was their habit that when they passed
through
the land of a particular chief they
would visit that chief and get
permission to pass through his land
then they would start doing this with
the jinn and say oh chief of the jinn
you know we're seeking your permission
to pass through your land
and this started to make the gin bold
right they started to make them
you know you know get some courage
because before they were terrified of
humans
right um so we have to understand that
and
apart from anything else we have you
know these
i don't know like one i remember one of
my teachers
i don't know if he was a teacher exactly
but he was more like you know
someone i knew he said you know the
suratul
and you know the last three verses
surahs of the quran
he said it's like a nuclear bomb against
shaytan and the jinn
right and actually you know when i first
became muslim bro i was so bothered by
shaytan like
really bro it was horrific like i would
i couldn't concentrate on my prayer
i i would literally bro i would make
sajdah
and like these images of ganesh and i
didn't even like you know like
follow him the images of ganesh would
come in my head
and like this voice would be saying stop
worshipping idols right stop worshiping
like this is just to disrupt my prayer
right i was so hard bro i couldn't
concentrate
and then i learned these three surahs
right in fact
funnily enough i only even learned them
in english i didn't even learn them in
arabic
i just was reading the translation of
the quran and came across them in
english because i was saying
you know i was just making dua allah
help me even in english
like 90 of the that
stuff stopped you know um so it's just
also knowing the right things to recite
you know those the three calls blow into
your hands
spit lightly like that recite the three
culls
you know recite it three times wipe it
over yourself three times wipe it over
yourself
like each one of allah
do one each and then wipe it again you
do it
each one then wipe it do that before you
go to bed
right recite ayatollah khorasi after
every followed
prayer try to be in wudu
right in a state of taharah as much as
you can
right if for example you have intimate
relationships with your wife
try to make sure you take russell
afterwards before you sleep or at least
make
tayamum you know on the wall or
something like that right
so it's just these things you know be
make the dua when you go in and out of
the toilet
right um it's things like and don't
urinate in places
like where the gin may be so that
there's some things that are just so
well known
anyone who studies this matter you will
find that all the scholars are saying
the same thing that
certain mistakes that people make a lot
that opens them up to being attacked by
the gin because it i
there's sort of protocols that exist
right they're sort of like i guess it's
a bit like traffic lights
and you know zebra crossings right that
type of stuff just we
just as we have protocols right um
that though those protocols exist in the
world of the shayateen and the gin and
this is by the way a bit of the way that
magic works right they have these
protocols but
even for us if we don't under see this
is the problem
if you don't understand this area of jin
and shayateen you will
you will cross the line right and when
you cross the line it opens the doors
for you to be attacked by the jinn
all right so when you don't make the dua
before you relieve yourself that you
verbalizing that dua all the becoming
you saying it just saying it the jinn
now know you're coming and they will get
out of the way
but if you just go and urinate you may
urinate on the jinn and they will attack
you and they will be their right
to attack you you won't be protected
because you abuse them
you transgress you oppress them do you
understand
so it's so important to know this stuff
it's this is why ignorance subhanallah
the dean
is so dangerous bro gotta be grounded in
a deen and let's close up with this uh
what do you say for our agnostic atheist
friends when they hear this they say oh
that's the reason i don't follow any
religion but at the same time
you know these are the people who are
really the most into aliens and ufos and
stuff like that
i mean and maybe you know that there is
a connection between aliens and ufos and
jin
you know maybe there is because you know
we know that jin have the ability to
you know i mean maybe we're talking
about the same thing you know maybe
yeah i mean it's just a different
language we call it jin
right um but maybe the you know maybe
the jin
and aliens are the same thing right
but you know just to say that like first
of all right
like you look throughout every culture
you look through history you look
through
every single culture historically right
even until today despite all the science
and
people universally have experienced
these creatures and believe in them they
may call them differently
they may call them ghosts or spirits or
gin
or lots of different things they may
even call them gods
right because they've taken them as gods
but in fact they're just the jinn
right which these people have begun to
worship but you will find that they you
know recognize they have these powers
they have these abilities they can
possess people so on and so forth
like so many people have witnessed it
extraordinary things happening that
are super human feats a human being
cannot do those things how do you
explain it
how do you explain have you not seen you
seen that video of that
that that woman who that i think in
norway was running across the road got
hit by a truck
and just got up and walked and kept
going well she wasn't on drugs right
it doesn't matter she's on drugs right
and she was fine
like and so many people countless
numbers of people will tell you these
stories like are they all lying
and they all made it up everywhere on
every culture throughout history
that is you know what that's
unscientific
to deny it is itself unscientific
right because that's science science is
built on observation
right and this stuff has been observed
right
okay what's the explanation for it fair
enough you know you can come up for an
explanation but you know from our
perspective
it is these beings why would why in a
universe
that is so huge and so massive right
when you have stuff that we've only
discovered that
the most of the universe is supposed to
be for example dark matter
are we saying it's not a possibility
that there is not some other type of
intelligent being that exists that is
not you know carbon based
that is maybe based on something else
why is that not a possibility
right of course it's a possibility it
would be it would be ridiculous to
discount it
so i mean you know like i'm not going to
convince you from that
a person from that you know but you know
you
surely it's not uh you know it's not
worthy of a mind that is open to inquiry
to consider these as possibilities right
um so yeah i don't think anyone should
dismiss this
outright that is just not really uh
that's not really being open to
possibilities which everyone should be
great conversation as always it's a
pleasure talking with you we could take
away from this
if anything strengthen your castle your
fortress
with the dean get well grounded in the
dean don't miss out on your card your
salah
five times a day your toe heed uh and
extra bonuses try to stay under we'll do
as much as possible
and anything else you want to add [ __ ]
no habibi that's it man it's so great to
be on the dean show
i hope we can do this again um and um
you know i'm gonna invite you into some
of my shows now eddie you're gonna have
to accept right
inshallah let's do it
bro inshallah and listen eddie you got
to start this dean shawn club house bro
i don't know if you've heard of
clubhouse clubhouse what's up getting
playing there
yeah it's it's really it's really
kicking off and it's amazing you'll have
some amazing conversations
i think you'd be great on that bro okay
clubhouse for inviting me on bro
may god almighty allah preserve you
protect you hope see you again soon
[Music]
subscribe right now